remember when we were discussing one
time and then me and gant were there
and it was you and then i think you were
like no people come for me from like my
super serious anime takes
i looked at gone i'm like what no you
said because you're like oh people come
to you because they like your
personality
no but they want my recommendations yeah
they were like and i looked at god i'm
like
no i was like back me up man back me up
a year and a half ago yeah yeah that's
when you were like i think you were
still getting this
i was getting the hang of it yeah but
even then i felt that your videos that
were recommending stuff it was still
like
people came for your personality not for
the recommendations yeah yeah
recommendations died yeah like five
years ago
nobody actually seeks recommendations on
youtube no no no no and i i want to just
be entertained for 10 minutes i don't
think about my day yeah i mean
the recommendation comes as like a plus
you know i mean
yeah to whatever the personality who is
presenting it
if i'm honest i mean i personally i
don't think i'm
anything you can't get anywhere
personality-wise but i
mean i don't come i don't want i'm not a
singer but i
please
[Laughter]
no but then um that's why i guess like
in a way i
don't think anyone who starts youtube
right away in the first like year thinks
of themselves as a personality like they
think like
oh i'm just doing stuff about anime yeah
it's not about me i mean it's it's
something you definitely grow into yeah
and
i don't i can't remember how long it's
it took me um
because it took me forever cindy you've
been doing youtube for like
how long now years almost oh my god
you're a youtube child
yeah with this kind of content obviously
with this kind of content yeah
uh about two years two and a half years
something like that like how's your
journey been
in that two years like growing honestly
i think i've started to accept
you know it's like kind of like at first
initially i'm like i don't deserve this
it doesn't feel like i've done anything
imposter syndrome yeah it's kind of like
a part
up until recently i had really bad dude
i still get impossible
like why are people even like
subscribing to me like i'm just like
really loud talking about titty like i
just say titty every like 50 times in
one minute
and but i guess recently i guess i'm
just starting to say like maybe i'm not
such a piece of [ __ ]
i self-confidence i think everyone feels
impossible yeah yeah i feel like when
another big creator that you like you
maybe respect is like yo i love your
stuff you're like
oh my god yeah yeah facebook [ __ ]
time
oh i love like i like your videos i'm
like stop trying to suck my dick
no you don't i i remember i had a i
remember who it was i got a dm from
someone they're like i like your videos
and i was
i was gonna reply but i was thinking
about it i was just panicking i'm like
are they [ __ ] with me
are they like are they joking are they
poking fun at me
it's always from that one youtuber that
you'd never thought you'd yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
why why why are you on my channel like i
[ __ ] love your videos man you're like
you're like every time i hear a
compliment my first reaction is just
why are you lying to me
i just assume they're being sarcastic
it's like where's the punchline just
tell me the punchline now just get it
over with i don't want to hear the rest
please say psyche